hi guys I'm Eric Boston ready player one
is a thrilling movie about obsessive
gamers pursuit of online Easter eggs and
as someone who basically does exactly
that on YouTube I think it broke me
there's there's so many damn easter eggs
and references and cameos and silent
links it's like Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory everything's edible egg flavored
and damn yeah
Wonka is one of the things referenced in
this movie so but uh sorry watch ready
player one
you know just turn it over and shake out
all the goodies that you might have
missed
I spotted over 300 things and rather
than just list them and have you take my
word for it I'm gonna show you where you
can find everything spoilers ahead and
uh let's get started okay even before
the movie starts director Steven
Spielberg throws us two little nods to
one of the biggest pop culture
touchstones of this movie Back to the
Future
notice how the opening titles are a
similar font and capitalization as the
way Back to the Future opens and right
as the Amblin name appears on screen
Amblin by the ways Spielberg's
production company we hear the music of
jump by Van Halen it's just a great 80s
rock song that plays well against Wade's
jumping down from his trailer home in
the stacks but also his jump into his
escape in the Oasis maybe do you really
want to stretch things cuz that's what
we do here Eddie Van Halen was also
Marty McFly's favorite guitarist
remember he uses it to torture his dad
into sleeping with his mom
real dark movie as Wade descends the
stacks he passes a neighbor who gets a
Pizza Hut delivery via drone this could
be yet another nod to Back to the Future
Part 2 where they depict how future
societies evolved by the way they get
their Pizza Hut weighed Greta's neighbor
mrs. Gilmore with another 80s music
reference she's wearing a shirt showing
the album cover of synchronicity by the
police then Wade brings us into his
hideout which is full of miserable
references to 80s gaming and toys if you
look closely you can see stickers for
the Garbage Pail Kids as well as
stickers for Qbert
Wade hangs his Oasis visor on a joystick
for the Commodore 64 game console and
the wall behind him as he puts on his
visor is an old Nintendo zapper you know
though one I used to shoot that smug
freaking dog the Markham you know kinda
connected there also a few references to
comics throughout this van Wade takes
off his glasses and sets him on an old
x-men lunchbox
also on Wade's visor he put a batman
sticker first a mini Caped Crusader
cameos in its movie then we get another
literary easter egg as Wade takes us
into the Oasis and one of the first
things we see is the planet ludus ludis
is a school planet in the Oasis it's one
of the few planets Wade can initially
afford to go to it's actually the hiding
place of the first key though that was
changed for the movie the Oasis is of
course a massive gaming platform so
there are also just a ton of game
references here as we see outer space
imagery the music is a choral chanting
which I feel like is a nod to the main
menu of Halo then we zoom into Minecraft
world a whole planet dedicated to
enthusiasts of the game Minecraft
there's also a sports themed universe
with a tennis ball planet which could be
a nod to Wii tennis we was of course one
of the first super popular interactive
home consoles that Ernest Cline used as
inspiration for the Oasis this montage
also contains some cinematic references
in the game hurricane hang-gliding one
of the houses floating in a cyclone
looks a lot like the Gale house and The
Wizard of Oz and as Wade says you can
climb Mount Everest with Batman we get a
double whammy of Batman references here
the version of Batman we actually see is
the Michael Keaton version but the fact
that he's scaling a cliffside is a nod
to the classic Adam West Batman where he
and Robin would scale the sides of
buildings that definitely weren't
actually horizontal I could get with
random 60 stars and then more references
pop up in the Oasis entrance Plaza
there's robe
cop and Marvin the Martian and then in
the walkway area there are more gaming
Easter eggs beneath the platform's sonic
the hedghog taps his foot waiting in
line to teleport and in front of Sonic
is tracer from overwatch then walking
behind Wade our Hello Kitty and his
known associates badtz-maru and keroppi
and then passing them is this hulking
figure this is Atticus from battle born
then Wade calls his buddy H who's
currently cleaning up on the planet doom
doom is a planet in the animated series
Voltron each his gun may be familiar to
you it's an MA 5b assault rifle from
halo this battle also features a ton of
giant scorpions which could be nods to
the robot scorpions and the ms-dos game
ultra BOTS and then H is various
Challenger should be familiar to you
Duke Nukem fires a rocket launcher
meanwhile Wade's odds boyfriend Rick
shows up as Jim Raynor from the
Starcraft PC game and one of the avatars
who dies is a little girl who has a
Donkey Kong jr. poster in her bedroom
for the movie cameos here Freddy Krueger
is another avatar each kills there's
also a cameo by Freddy's longtime rival
Jason Voorhees and the gun that H picks
up and adds to the inventory is an e/m
one rail gun from the movie eraser I
also like how the artifact of this
battle is the gregarious 120 it's a
gauntlet that allows two interrupted
minutes as a gigantic mech in game the
reason we see the series it's setting up
Dido later fighting as the Gundam in the
final battle then behind wait here
there's an avatar wearing the yellow
suit and red shirt the Doc Brown wore
when he came back from the future and
back to the future and the pop-culture
references continue as Wade introduces
us to James Halliday music here is Tears
for Fears
everybody wants to rule the world which
was featured prominently in the 1999 TV
movie pirates of Silicon Valley which is
considered the most accurate biopic of
the rise of people like Bill Gates and
Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak
and that's essentially what we're seeing
here this tech press conference is shot
to look a lot like the ones given by
Steve Jobs back in the day the
relationship between Halliday and Moro
is modeled on the one between Wozniak
and jobs with Halliday is the more
introverted engineer who lets his
partner do all the sales pitching though
unlike Wozniak Holliday actually becomes
the more worshipped of the two actually
in Wade's van there is a newspaper
clipping and comparing Halliday to Steve
Jobs Mark Rylance his performance is one
of the best parts of this movie it's
blank stare and shy mumble seems to
evoke Garth Dana Carvey character from
yes Annelle sketching movies from the
80s and 90s the joke Halliday makes here
check under your seats and you'll find
there's nothing there is a nod to Oprah
Winfrey's famous card giveaway stunts
and holidays will and testament video is
full of more nods whole room is
decorated with star trek regalia the
flower arrangements and the stained
glass form the shape of the Star Trek
logo and the Starship Enterprise itself
getting even nerdier with it check out
his coffin this is the same black mark 6
pod and flag that Spock's remains were
put in after his death at the end of the
movie the Wrath of Khan as holiday Rises
out of the coffin there's an organ riff
as he creepily sits up paula zahn homage
to the old classic Dracula films his
announcement of an Easter egg hunt to
take over his company was of course
inspired by Willy Wonka's golden ticket
contest from Charlie's Chocolate Factory
and yeah holiday is certainly a Wonka
figure in fact Spielberg actually wanted
Gene Wilder to play the part before Gene
Wilder passed away Halladay is wizard
avatar is an Iraq and his appearance
seems to evoke the character Nicodemus
from the secret of NIMH that was created
by Don Bluth who's an old Spielberg
collaborator there also some interesting
nods to gaming here on his eyes Halliday
has quarters from his birth year 1972
now the quarter becomes a key idea for
this whole movie it's the cost of
playing an old score Kade game which
back in the day opened kids up to a
whole new life of exploration later
we'll see more Oh disguised as the robot
curator in holidays archives giving pars
of all 1/4 which literally becomes an
extra life at the end of the movie in
the epilogue of the movie Wade reveals
that Mauro's requested salaries only 25
cents a quarter essentially this coin
here marks this movie's transition from
death at the beginning to life at the
end Holliday also wears a few buttons on
his blazer here one shows the game Simon
and another one that's a little harder
to see it has a 20-sided die of course
20 cent die are used in Dungeons &
Dragons and I know this has been pointed
out before but the whole title image of
this movie is itself a game
the letters form a maze that leads to
this little Easter egg in the center and
for even more eggs let's move on to this
race for the copper key first the music
being played here this is Joan Jett and
the Blackhearts I hate myself for loving
you it's kind of the perfect anthem for
all of these Gunter's for their
relentless obsession with holidays
heartbreaking impossible race and death
buckle up because there are a ton of
movie and TV references here parseval's
car is that
Lorien from back to the future it's also
the car he drives in the book except
here does not have the Ghostbusters
logos printed on these side doors or the
ability to pass through solid matter or
the license plate ecto 88 instead the
license plate here says it's named parts
of all the DeLoreans interior is
accurate to back to the future with a
flux capacitor and a time circuit board
if you look closely the destination and
origin dates are set to 1985 a 1955 as
they are in the movie but the present
day has been updated to 2045 when ready
player one takes place and notice how
the DeLorean has this glowing red bar on
the grille now that is from kit a night
writer so even though we don't hear it
Wade has actually updated this car with
an internal voice AI first of all look
is also an amalgamation of references
his hip holster is the same one worn by
Han Solo in Star Wars and his belt
buckle is imprinted with a Thundercats
logo the back of his vest is embroidered
with a golden sword a reference to pars
Vols name origin Percival the boy from
the legends of King Arthur and Holy
Grail and H disses his haircut by
calling it there's something about meri
hair which is a nod to win Cameron Diaz
put something in or do that definitely
wasn't hair gel other car is visible and
this includes 60s Batmobile Ford
interceptor for Mad Max Christine the
killer Plymouth Fury from the Stephen
King novel and movie the band from the
a-team in the Mach 5 from Speed Racer
later in the race you can see another
version of a kit from Knight Rider and
then a super subtle cameo from the
Griswold station wagon from the national
lampoon's vacation movie and of course
Artemis's motorcycle which is canada's
bike from the anime film akira the t-rex
that chases them through the streets
appears to be a nod to Spielberg's chase
scene in Jurassic Park must go faster
and King Kong makes a cameo clutching
the Empire State Building while biplanes
as it passed as he does in the classic
film and the Peter Jackson remake and on
the street they passed a movie theater
marquee reading Schwarzenegger Jack
Slater 3 and that's a nod to the movie
Last Action Hero where Jack Slater is a
movie within the movie
and back at ioi the researchers have a
map from the movie Escape from New York
behind them on the wall suggesting this
version of Liberty Island is a modified
version of the one that we saw in that
movie again the city is also a mix of
different influences because Artemis
jumps past a billboard for Delta City
that's the name of the futuristic
Detroit in the movie Robocop the
sequence also has a bunch of gaming
Easter eggs a chess car is Bigfoot one
of the first famous monster trucks to
launch the trend of monster truck
rallies and toys there are also cameos
by Ryu from Street Fighter Lara Croft
from Tomb Raider and Izzy from Gears of
War and one of the other cars is a red
Formula One car from the classic Atari
game pole position Artemis is a Keira
bike has a bunch of gaming related
stickers one for Sega miss pac-man Hello
Kitty and Taito the Japanese game
company there's also a logo for the 80s
TV show Greatest American Hero
so if you nod to comics here on the bike
there's also sticker with a Wonder Woman
logo and later after pars of all saves
Artemis from King Kong ace chemicals is
visible in the background ace chemicals
is from the DC Comics it's where the
Joker fell into the BATF acid next we
move on to H's workshop in which
everything is once again a reverence
first as they walk through the door you
can see the stolen bike from pee-wee's
big adventure and of course there's the
Iron Giant the least subtle pop culture
now to this movie it's not miscible no
one missed it change Thank You H his
lunch box is a print of Fraggle Rock the
Jim Henson kids show and inside are
small versions of the Galactica from the
Battlestar Galactica the Sulaco the ship
and aliens and the spaceship Valley
Forge which is a deeper cut from the 70s
movies silent running on the racks
behind them you can see the Eagle 5 the
Winnebago from Mel Brooks's space balls
the yellow cargo loader from aliens
though some say it looks more like the
thing from EXO squad the 80209 killer
police droid from Robocop the red
swordfish to ship from the anime cowboy
bebop the eda pod from Kubrick's 2001 a
Space Odyssey the Viper fighter from
Battlestar Galactica
Buck Rogers Thunder fighter from the 70s
80s TV show Buck Rogers in the 25th
century and the red 1961 Ferrari GT
California that belonged to Cameron's
dad and Ferris Bueller's Day Off
this scene also features parts of all
and Artemis quoting holidays favorite
movie line from Superman some people can
read war and peace and come away
thinking it's a simple adventure story
others can read the ingredients on a
chewing-gum wrapper the universe in
Artemis calls parts of all McFly not to
back to the future future it's always
back to there also some gaming
references in the scene parts of all
quickly mentions Arrakis is a virtual
destination that's a place in dune and
he and Artemis also mentioned the Atari
2600 racer game turbo as well as
Goldeneye the classic and 64 Bond
shooter they say Halliday preferred
slappers only mode which means players
can only fight unarmed and his favorite
character is odd-job which makes sense
for anyone who played Goldeneye our job
is significantly shorter than anyone
else and impossible to kill and before I
move on I love the music references here
the song that each plays in the
background is just my imagination by the
temptations basically trolling party
balls one-sided infatuation with Artemis
in this moment they also mentioned that
holidays favorite song is video killed
the radio star by the Buggles and it's
easy to see why holiday loved it it was
the first music video ever to air on MTV
in 1981 and it marked a historic
transition to a more interactive virtual
mass medium just like holidays invention
of the Oasis did however they say
holidays favorite video was take on me
by a-ha which is also fitting because it
shows live-action characters entering an
animated world becoming part of the
stories of their imagination just like
users in the Oasis then we move back to
the stacks where Wade Watts explains the
origin of its name dropping two Marvel
Comics references dad take that name
because it sounded like a superhero's
alter-ego like Peter Parker or Bruce
Banner as parts of all visits holidays
journals we hear the song faith by
George Michael and this moment pars vol
is trying to keep the faith and keep his
eyes on the prize not get too distracted
by Artemis
the archives section has a few more
gaming nods behind the curator is a
tempest Atari game in the book tempest
plays a role in the final key challenge
then in the memory of Halladay and Mauro
Holliday mentions the game asteroids as
an example of a simple pleasure that
never needs
also holiday wears a Space Invaders
t-shirt and there's a poster of Galaga
on the wall behind him there's also some
movie references here the layout of the
archives building is designed to be a
replica of the high school library and
The Breakfast Club with the same
furniture in staircases that high school
actually comes up later also holidays
memory mentions wanting to go backwards
but the pedal to the metal like Bill and
Ted a reference to Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure where the guys went
back in time first of all uses this glue
to win the race and the copper key where
he's greeted by interact with the phrase
nice racing Padawan chorus padawan is
the word for Jedi trainee from the Star
Wars prequels the next scene shows
Nolan's Sorento pitching his evil Oasis
monetization plan to the Board of
Directors and this isn't really
reference to anything but notice how the
IOI logo makes a pattern when it's
repeated on the screen visually it kind
of looks like a string of binary code
ones and zeros to me this kind of
reflects the basic impersonal nature of
the ioi the corporate level and the
sixers they're just really a string of
numbers moving on to pars of all and h's
shopping spree at avatar outfitters wage
it feels like a possible reference to
the store Urban Outfitters hears he buys
a Holy Hand Grenade which is a powerful
weapon from the Monty Python and the
Holy Grail he also buys the Zemeckis
cube which is in the shape of a Rubik's
Cube it's a reference to Robert Zemeckis
director of Back to the Future Z will
use both of these later and there's a
bunch of kiosks in this place where you
can purchase combat moves including one
for Looney Tunes but most of them are
from game related world so you can also
see one for street fighter showing Ryu
doing a shuriken uppercut foreshadowing
Z using a different move from Street
Fighter at a key point later on they're
also kiosks for overwatch halo DMD and
Borderlands and then checking in with
Nolan Sorento in Iraq there are some
really fun details here searches
password which he stupidly has to write
on a post-it note to remember it his
numbers and letters spelling out bossman
69 and if you look closely at their
meeting place it's in the rumble of one
of the Martian tripods from Spielberg's
movie were the worlds the box that
contains the orb that IRA gives Sorento
is it's only Easter Egg it's the same
box that gizmo was delivered in in the
movie gremlins IROC also references the
old Tootsie Pop commercial from the 80s
the box's contents is the orb of our
civics
which takes the shape of a 20-sided die
another D&D reference and for a few
literary references it's interesting how
Sorento
is avatar a little hair curl perhaps
referencing Superman if so it's
interesting that Sorento would identify
was Superman while holidays favorite
quote was a Lex Luthor line perhaps a
reflects Sorrento is a shallow poseur
compared to the more complex thoughtful
holiday also when I rock holds up the
skull he says the steampunk Pirate King
I knew him well Sorento that's a
reference to Shakespeare's Hamlet when
Hamlet famously holds a skull of his
jester and says alas poor Yorick I knew
him Horatio it often gets misquoted as I
knew him well as I Rock does here with
his joke but I'll just I'll just go back
to the theater nerd table moving on when
the rest of the high five when the
copper key show wins by driving up of
what looks like a 77 Pontiac Firebird
Trans Am the car that Burt Reynolds
drove and smokey in the bandits
definitely smoking here it's literally
on fire and as part of all makes his way
back to Holidays journals we have more
great eighties music with Blondie's one
way or another reflecting the
competitive gun teen craze that pars
Vols discovery has inspired he gets
greeted by a ton of cameos from games
there's Batman from the Arkham Knight
games Lara Croft popping up again Jill
Valentine from the Resident Evil games
Supergirl from the injustice games in
the comics and of course Goro for mortal
combat who's really Artemis in disguise
there's also more movie references here
with Beetlejuice also among the fans and
Artemis scaring Z with a chest burster
from the Alien franchise Christopher
Reeves depiction of Clark Kent gets
referenced with the Clark Kent glasses
that Artemus makes Z where to blend in
and in the second holiday more oh memory
holiday talks about his lost love Karen
who went by Keira a reference to the
character in the Dark Crystal
Artemis refers to her as holidays
rosebud reverencing the movie Citizen
Kane which revolved around search for a
missing emotional influence on a
deceased eccentric billionaire also some
fun music references here holiday has a
Billy Idol album on his desk and if you
listen closely when Artemis asks Z out
you can hear the sound of a Mario 1up
moving on to H's basement where there
are even more music references pars
vault tries on various outfits including
Prince's Purple Rain trench coat Michael
Jackson's Thriller outfit and an outfit
inspired by Duran Duran there also some
gaming references here H has a tabletop
version of pac-man and Z's Punk outfit
has the letters DK on the back perhaps a
reference to Donkey Kong and movie in
teeny Easter eggs or
there's a neon sign reading cocktails
and dreams which is from the Tom Cruise
movie cocktail there's also a vintage
poster for Mad Max in parts of all
settles on an outfit inspired by the
movie buckaroo banzai
you may also spot a TARDIS from Doctor
Who in that room and a shirt saying Save
Ferris from Ferris Bueller's Day Off and
there are two fun political posters one
shows the actor will Wheaton who in the
world of ready player one is a vice
president of the Oasis in real life he
narrated the audio book for Klein's
novel another says reelect mayor Goldie
Wilson which is reference to Back to the
Future Goldie Wilson was Hill valleys
mayor who Marti inspired to run for
office when Goldie was still sweeping
floors to the diner moving on to the
distracted globe nightclub with even
more movie and TV references line of
ships headed toward the planet feature
the serenity from Firefly and some have
spotted an x-wing from Star Wars and a
group of ships inside the club are Conan
the Barbarian and Gandalf from Lord of
the Rings and Hobbit spinning among the
dancers there's also some DC Comics
cameos Z passes Deathstroke on the way
into the club Harley Quinn used to be
with him in an early trailer but now she
appears to be dancing with the Joker
there also some gaming cameos from
Street Fighter chun-li and Blanca show
up behind Artemis of the bar who's also
a cameo by Commander Shepard from Mass
Effect wearing his inset an armor the
music references here are also grave at
first you can hear Blue Monday by new
order new order used to be the band Joy
Division who makes its own cameo in the
movie later on also the bartender is
wearing a red energy dome hat worn by
the band Devo and then after Rosie and
Artemis take the leap and dance Z throws
out a disco dance floor and plays the
Bee Gees stayin alive there's all the
reference to their music and the scene
from Saturday Night Fever
then the ioy soldiers birthday and the
gage at a shootout giving us some fun
references with these weapons Horus Vols
Blaster is a starlight pistol from the
80s laser tag game and one of Artemis's
handguns is a Magnum pistol from Halo
those who play halo know this one is a
crazy deadly pistol and a game
programmer doubled the damage of right
before the game shipped out rather hand
gun is a movie reference it's lawgiver
used by Judge Dredd and before she pulls
these out she actually uses a bigger gun
it's an m40 one a pulse rival the same
kind used by Ripley and aliens the
sequence ends with the awesome call back
to these Zemeckis
cube which Z reveals can rewind time 60
seconds moment this happens you can hear
music cue from the Back to the Future
score alan silvestri who composed Back
to the Future it's awesome composer on
this movie moving on to Wade's
confrontation with Sorento rental offers
Wade a Millennium Falcon from Star Wars
which is apparently really rare in the
Oasis and these two test each other's
80s trivia knowledge with weed saying
Ridgemont or faber referencing the
movies fast times of Ridgemont High and
Animal House which takes place at Faber
College meanwhile Sorrento's researchers
are really in Azir helping them remember
the name of Shermer high school which is
the name of the fictional high school
and both Ferris Bueller's Day Off and
The Breakfast Club both directed by John
Hughes Sorento goes on to say he just
wants to drink tab play Robotron listen
to Duran Duran irreverent scene the
popular tab soft drink from the 80s they
gave Robotron and yeah the band and
after Wade turns him down and Sorrento
threatens his home in the stacks some
shots of the graffiti drawn on those
trailers includes this blue mad ball toy
reptile mat balls actually show up again
later as an explosive speaking of this
graffiti others have said that they
spotted Raven from Teen Titans among all
this artwork moving on when Wade meets
Samantha face-to-face she's wearing a
Joy Division shirt Joy Division is that
eighties band that became new order and
later when she figures out the second
clue we see that her Oh ASA speiser has
a Batman sticker on it as well just like
Wade's did in the journals the high five
mentions a few 80s movies that were
playing on the weekend Halliday went on
his one date with Keira the remake of
the fly directed by David Cronenberg say
anything and Spielberg's movie
firestarter is also visible among those
okay now we move on to my favorite part
of the movie
Spielberg's shot-for-shot recreation of
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining guys
there's just so much I loved about the
sequence so I'm gonna point out all the
little details that were just like
perfectly nails first the name of the
movie theater that they go into is the
Overlook which is the name of the
haunted hotel in the shining
also a poster for Return of the Jedi is
visible outside the movie theater the
creepy synth music that place here is
the exact score from the opening shots
of The Shining composed by Wendy Carlos
and Rachel elk and this wide shot of the
Overlook Lobby is the same angle Kubrick
used in the movie when Wendy swings the
bat at Jack as he follows her up the
stairs and this upward-facing shot of
PARs vols face looking down to the
typewriter is the same
of Wendy when she learns what Jack's
really been writing all this time same
goes for the typewritten pages with the
text and various shapes we also get
little cameos by the tennis ball that
rolls up to Danny rolls up to H here the
Grady twins the blood elevator
slow-motion shot the final group
photograph with Halladay and Kyra in
place of jack room 237 in the beautiful
/ terrifying woman inside the ax coming
through the door the hedge maze the
walk-in freezer
Danny's big wheel and the sliding pan
into the gold room and throw this
Silvestri resamples The Shining score
with the creepy string music as well as
the 20s dance music that placed the end
of the movie Artemis is one who makes it
to the second key and she gets the next
clue which makes two number references
the answer ultimate is a reference to
the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy the
answer to the ultimate question of life
the universe and everything is 42 the
clue also references the number magic
which refers to the schoolhouse rock
song in which 3 is magic number divided
in 42 by 3 is how they got 14 which is a
sector where the final key is hidden
actually if you look closely at Wade and
Samantha's notes you can see the
brainstorm that deduced all of this the
notes reference I am 1 Sanchez
Villalobos Ramirez aligned from
Highlander and the other side of this
notebook lists the movies gremlins Dark
Crystal Temple of Doom crawl splash
helms deep from Lord of the Rings the
two towers and Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy okay now jumping ahead here Wade
meets H in real life Helen along with
die toe slash to Shiro and show her van
and her clothes feature a ton of
references first the back door has this
image that's from the tomb of horrors
and dungeons of dragons the book that
was actually the location of the first
key also tashera has a pin on his jacket
with the logo from mortal kombat
meanwhile show is wearing this s
letterman jacket now the S could just be
for his name show and the yellow for the
colors of his avatar but to me this kind
of looks like Emilio Estevez his
letterman jacket from The Breakfast Club
different colors but the S patch and the
little thing in the middle of it kind of
the same there's also another Batman
sticker in the back of the van because
they're everywhere and then there's HS
jacket with a ton of patches there's one
for fender cats and the lips logo from
Rocky Horror Picture Show and then
there's a few DC comic related ones a
patch for the Wonder Woman W logo
another with Diana with her arms crossed
and another for Supergirl
okay as we see io I try to unlock the
third key the whiteboard behind the
researchers shows Aizen
as one of the possible locations that's
the home of Saruman from Lord of the
Rings and the final key is hidden among
a series of classic Atari 2600 games
centipede pitfall haunted house berserk
defenders sword quest motocross and
adventurer all get shoutouts adventure
we find out is actually crucial to the
ending and it's part of the book as well
it's considered one of the first ever
Easter eggs in the video game in which
the game designer Warren Robinett coated
his name into it after Atari refused to
really give credits for royalties
recognition to developers they're also
more movie references the Sixers falling
through the ice could be a reference to
the Dark Knight Rises when condemned
Gothamites were forced by Bane's forces
to walk out on thin ice and the phrase
that IROC speaks as the incantation to
activate the orb might sound familiar to
you it's the spell from movie Excalibur
[Music]
when Wade and Toshiro trapped Sorrento
in the Oasis when he thinks he's in
reality notice the eyes of the fake
avatars have weighed in Toshiro they
glow in this orange white color this
could be a nod to Blade Runner where you
could tell if someone was a replicant if
their eyes glowed this color also this
may just be me but dye does whole look
here with a suit the silence are gone is
he traps a target in a dream world
pretending it's reality
just seems like a plot point at least
inspired by the movie Inception because
that's essentially what the extractors
are doing with just gordon-levitt
looking off lies he's trapped and
Cillian Murphy and then we get a quick
throwaway reference to this Nancy Drew
books
Samantha sees them on Sorrento's console
but really the easter eggs start to pour
in when Wade makes his call to arms
speech the projector device that he uses
to transmit his speech is a magic 8-ball
toy he also references the Gunter clans
and the gold mines of Gygax Gygax is a
nod to Gary Gygax the co-creator of
Dungeons & Dragons and then the waves of
Gunter's arrive and you can see
Battletoads from the Nintendo games it's
pimple and rash there's also appearance
from one of the cows two ostriches who
had a big cameo in the trailer but
really only showed up here in the movie
and the book wait actually has to win a
game of joust to win the copper key who
are also cameos by battle born
characters El Dragoon Ambra and Toby
Cassie cage for Mortal Kombat the
Spartans from Halo and Big Daddy from
Bioshock tracer Lara Croft in chun-li
returning as well
there's also quick shots of Sonic and
Tails the female Shepard from Mass
Effect 3 and
got from Street Fighter and then there
are some cameos from DC Comics The Joker
returns along with spawn and Batgirl
Catwoman shows up running alongside
tracer and Deadshot definitely make some
parents a wide shot of the battle also
shows the giant Cyclops from these seven
voyages of Sinbad and yeah lots and lots
of movie references leading the charge
in the opening wave looks like toca from
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles - the
secret of the use there are also cameos
by the transformer Optimus Prime D man
Deadites from the Evil Dead movies
Chuckie from child's play and a cameo
that the animators snuck in at surprise
Steven Spielberg himself a few gremlins
here I Rock puts his hand on Sorrento's
shoulder and says no man is a failure
who has friends it's a reference to the
movie It's a Wonderful Life the angel
Clarence wrote it to George Bailey in
the book that he gave them at the end
and of course parts of all holds the
stereo bruised head referencing John
Cusack said more to move and say
anything but instead of Peter Gabriel's
in your eyes he plays Twisted Sisters
we're not gonna take it which is really
the perfect rebel anthem for these
Gunter's to open war against io I
now there's a ton of other Easter eggs
and cameos in this section that I'm
still trying to figure out where one is
now it's tough because a lot of people
are just saying it's Word of God I saw
Iron Man and Pikachu did you know
because you bank ready player one would
highlight to those cameos with their own
big cool shots that no one would miss
guys those are bigger gets than Chucky
and Battletoads but here's a quick list
of ones that I'm pretty sure I spotted
mercy and doom fist from overwatch
arbiter and grunt from Halo Red Lion
from Voltron sub-zero and Raiden for
Mortal Kombat Aquaman the flash in Blue
Beetle from DC Comics and the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles but I'll have to
re-watch to find exactly where I saw
them but then Sorento brings up his
display to summon the Mechagodzilla from
of course the Godzilla movies to fight
H's Iron Giant but before he does if you
look closely at this display one of the
options looks a lot like Megatron from
Transformers title fights Mechagodzilla
by using HS Gregorius 122 become a
gundam to be specific it's an rx-78 to
Mobile Suit Edo Artemis shoots a hole in
mechagodzilla's eye and tosses in
another one of these mad ball toys
explodes like a massive grenade and when
she gets to the steps of anoraks castle
she uses this chainsaw lancer rifle now
this is from the Gears of War though
Artemis only fires it as a blaster
rather than using that chainsaw function
bummer after IROC blows
a cheese is iron Giants body as a bridge
to let the others cross now this could
be a reference to the way Superman used
his body to bridge the gap for a train
full of innocence show uses his five
bladed pinwheel to cut off Iraq's arm
this is the glaive from the movie crawl
which was referenced earlier and when
Iron Giant falls in the lava it gives a
big thumbs up this is a reference to the
end of Terminator 2 when Arnold's t100
lowers into the molten metal with the
Skynet tech and leaves John Connor with
a friendly thumbs up inside the castle
parts of all forces Artemis to leave
them behind an escape from ioi
and he shoots her with this particular
gun this is a blaster from Battlestar
Galactica and we get a callback of the
Holy Hand Grenade notice that when it
explodes it takes out all the sixers
making the sound of an angelic choir
just like it doesn't Monty Python
meanwhile out in the real world
io I chases down the high fives van in
the street and H makes this Mario
reference and back inside the oasis
parts of all takes out sorrento with a
hadouken fireball attack it's the move
from street fighter of course parts ball
probably picked it up from that kiosk
earlier then when sorrento moves to
activate the cataclysm I rock calls it a
quote camper move
now that's gaming lingo used for newbies
who camp out and hard-to-reach spots
near respawning ammo or weapons
basically it's kind of like cheating
because he's suck and that's what
sorrento is doing here but parsable
survives thanks to this extra life from
OGG you find the Easter egg and
adventure and reaches the final Easter
Egg I noticed the pedestal the two
dragons from the logo of the game Mortal
Kombat also if you look in the
background there are statues of Mortal
Kombat characters Raiden sub-zero and
scorpion Percival refuses to sign the
contract and interact moved by his
nobility takes them to Halliday's
childhood bedroom with more little
Easter eggs there's a poster for the
game doused Robby the Robot toy from
Forbidden Planet a pacman poster and a
statue of King Kong the Atari game that
young holiday is plane is gorf and
holidays final words to parts of all are
thank you for playing my game which
could be a nod to super mario 64 after
the credits roll mario says thank you so
much you're booked to playing in my game
in a few movie references here the VHS
the eighties movie interspace can be
seen on holidays shelf along with a
poster for the movie lady hawk one
Computers is an inside atat which is the
computer matthew broderick uses to hack
NORAD in the movie war games for games
actually a big part of the second key in
the book Halliday's showing Wade this
red button looks like yet another wink
at Willie Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory which ended with Wonka showing
Charlie a red button in the elevator
beforehand not the keys to his empire
then during the scene Holliday quotes
classic film star Groucho Marx saying
I'm not crazy about reality but it's
still the only place to get a decent
meal this is essentially holidays final
lesson Wade that as fun as it is to
escape in the Oasis it cannot completely
replace real life you may have also
noticed the poster for the Rush album
2012 the lyrics of which actually play a
major role in the book as well remember
each is actually wearing the art for
this problem on their t-shirt meanwhile
out in the real world Wade's neighbor
mrs. Gilmore returns and now her shirt
has changed from the police to one
showing the technique album by new order
and we get one last Silvestri Back to
the Future music sting when Sorrento
gets punched in the face its moment
evokes how good it felt it back to the
future to see the bad guy get whomped in
the mouth something you should not do in
real life cuz a bunch of people in the
face can even kill people the final
scene leaves us with a few lovely Easter
eggs
Wade's new apartment features the
life-size statue of Robbie the robot as
well as an arcade game revenge from Mars
an evil look closely in the background
Wade place a Star Trek Klingon bat'leth
on the windowsill sorry if I
mispronounced that tricky and on the far
left you can make out an r2d2 toy
finally the music that plays over the
credits is hollow notes do you make my
dreams come true spielberg chose this
song after learning it was the music
that ernest cline and his wife walked
down the aisle to at their wedding and
he is right it is exactly the song that
plays in every nerds heart when he
imagines making out with his dream girl
keyword imagines movies in real life
boom okay I think I'm dead that's a lot
of Easter eggs guys maybe you got a few
of these on your own hopefully we'll
find even more stuff whenever this movie
comes out an HD blu-ray just kind of
stare at the screen to find everything
in the meantime here's my question for
you guys what would be your avatar in
the Oasis me course I'd go as Sam
batcher obviously comment down below
with your thoughts or tweet me directly
I da vas and follow new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video shoot around subscribe to the
rockstars written to three times on all
the stuff you love thanks for watching
bye